This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Last fall, producer Chris Berube found himself in an aerospace museum just outside of Washington, D.C. The museum is inside a large aircraft hangar, with rows and rows of warplanes and Air Force uniforms and even an iconic American spaceship. The Space Shuttle Discovery looks, it almost looks like a cardboard replica of the Space Shuttle Discovery. Like it doesn't look real up close. This is amazing. Chris also found some exhibits that were less exciting. Male astronauts could wear a urine collection hose and bag assembly. This is literally just a diaper in a glass case.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。去年秋天，制作人克里斯·贝鲁比发现自己身处华盛顿特区郊外的一个航空博物馆里。博物馆坐落在一个巨大的飞机机库内，里面陈列着一排又一排的战机、空军制服，甚至还有一艘具有美国代表性的宇宙飞船。“发现号”航天飞机看起来，几乎就像是“发现号”航天飞机的纸板复制品。近看感觉不太真实。这太棒了。克里斯还发现了一些没那么令人兴奋的展品。男宇航员可以佩戴尿液收集软管和收集袋组件。这其实就是一个玻璃展柜里的纸尿裤。
This is not what I'm looking for. Okay, keep walking. The museum was cool, but I was getting impatient. That's because I was in Virginia for a very particular reason. I was there to see a jet pack. And according to the website for this museum, they had one. I just wasn't having any luck finding it. Okay, I haven't found the jetpack, but I have found a mailbox that looks like R2-D2.
这不是我要找的。好吧，继续走。博物馆很酷，但我开始不耐烦了。那是因为我去弗吉尼亚州有一个非常特殊的原因。我是去那里看喷气背包的。根据这家博物馆的网站，他们有一个。我只是运气不好没找到。好吧，我没找到喷气背包，但我找到了一个长得像R2-D2的邮箱。
Okay, why is it this this hasn't even gone to space? Why is this here? I know it may sound, I don't know, immature for a 30-something year old man to wander around a museum and mutter to himself about the lack of jetpacks inside the museum, but hear me out, I had a really good reason. When I was a kid, my dad used to work at a hydro plant in Niagara Falls, and when he came home, he'd tell me and my brother all these stories about his time at work, like pranks or travel to interesting places, but there was one story my brother and I never got tired of hearing
好吧，为什么这东西甚至都没去过太空？为什么它会在这里？我知道，对于一个三十多岁的男人来说，在博物馆里闲逛，还一边喃喃自语地抱怨博物馆里没有喷气背包，这可能听起来，我不知道，有点不够成熟，但听我说，我有一个很好的理由。当我还是个孩子的时候，我爸爸曾在尼亚加拉瀑布的水电站工作，他回家后，会把他在那里工作的故事讲给我和哥哥听，比如恶作剧或者去有趣的地方旅行，但有一个故事我和哥哥怎么听也听不腻。
about. According to my dad, one of his coworkers had a jetpack. At least, my dad thought he did. Apparently this guy knew how to fly a jetpack, and my dad told us he even talked about putting one on the roof of the plant, I guess in case of emergencies. For years, Chris wasn't sure if this jetpack man existed, or if jetpacks even existed. My dad died in 2010, so I never had a chance to ask him about this as a journalist. For years, I just had this story in the back of my head, but the details never totally added up. For example, according to my dad, the jet pack guy had flown one in the movie Superman 2.
据我爸爸说，他的一个同事有一个喷气背包。至少，我爸爸是这么认为的。显然这个人知道怎么开喷气背包，我爸爸告诉我们，他甚至还谈过把背包装在电站屋顶上的事，我猜是为了以防紧急情况。多年来，克里斯不确定这个喷气背包男是否真的存在，甚至不确定喷气背包是否真的存在。我爸爸于2010年去世，所以我再也没有机会作为一个记者去问他这件事了。多年来，这个故事一直留在我脑海深处，但细节始终说不通。例如，据我爸爸说，那个喷气背包男在电影《超人2》里飞过。
So I watched Superman 2 and you know what? There's no jet pack. I started to wonder, did my dad make this up to entertain us? I mean, there surely wasn't some guy flying around Southern Ontario with a jet pack in the early 90s. So I didn't put too much stock in it. It was just some family story.
所以我看了《超人2》，你猜怎么着？根本没有喷气背包。我开始纳闷，我爸是为了逗我们开心才编了这个故事吗？我的意思是，90年代初安大略省南部绝对没有哪个家伙背着喷气背包到处飞。所以我没太把这当回事。这不过是个家庭故事而已。
A thing I would tell people at parties, kind of half remembering all the details. But it turns out I wasn't alone. So this story for me really started from a memory. I wasn't even sure it was a real memory that I had. This is David Taylor. He grew up in Washington, D.C. in the 1960s, and he had something similar. His own hazy half-memories about a jetpack guy. I just had this image in my mind of a figure dressed in a white kind of an astronaut suit
一个我在派对上会讲给别人听的故事，所有的细节都有点记不清了。但事实证明我并不孤单。所以这个故事对我的启发其实源于一段记忆。我甚至不确定那是不是我真实拥有的记忆。这是大卫·泰勒。他在20世纪60年代在华盛顿特区长大，他也有过类似的经历。他自己对一个喷气背包男有一些模糊的半记忆。我的脑海里一直有这样一幅画面：一个穿着白色宇航员式套装的人影
hovering over the National Mall. David also wasn't sure if this memory was real until he started looking through the archives. I found a photo from the Washington Post in 1967 of a guy wearing a jet pack on the mall who was giving this demonstration at this pageant of transportation. It's sort of twin canisters on a backpack.
盘旋在国家广场上空。大卫也不确定这段记忆是否真实，直到他开始翻阅档案馆。我找到了《华盛顿报》1967年的一张照片，上面是一个家伙在广场上背着喷气背包，在这个交通盛会上进行示范。它的背包上有点像双筒罐。
It has sort of an arm, a metal arm on either side. It was like a motorcycle handlebar, but running back to his back instead of in front of him. The photos were proof. David really had seen a jet pack in action. I felt completely validated and I was thrilled. And I thought, okay, this can be the start of actually something that's a story that I would be part of rather than just some unrooted dream. David wrote about his experience for the Washington Post. And after I read his article, I realized two things.
它的两边各有一个手臂，一个金属手臂。就像摩托车的车把一样，只不过是伸到他背后面，而不是在他前面。照片就是证据。大卫确实亲眼见过喷气背包大显身手。我感到完全被证实了，我欣喜若狂。我想，好吧，这可以成为某个故事的开始，一个我会参与其中的故事，而不仅仅是一个无根无据的梦想。大卫为《华盛顿报》撰写了关于他的经历的文章。在我读了他的文章后，我意识到两件事。
One was that his jetpack guy, the one he saw back in 1967, he sounded suspiciously like my dad's jetpack guy. But the other thing I realized is that absolutely definitively, jetpacks are real. American scientists actually developed one back in the 60s, and it worked pretty well. 50 years ago, magazines were filled with claims that pretty soon there'd be a jetpack in every garage. The jetpack seemed like the future. It's not just me and David who have been obsessed with this search for a jetpack. For decades, scientists, lots of people have tried to bring the jetpack into reality. So what happened? Why has the jetpack fallen off our radar? Ever since humans have dreamt of flying through the air, in defiance of God, we have wanted
一是他的喷气背包男，也就是他在1967年看到的那个，听起来可疑地像我爸爸的喷气背包男。但我意识到的另一件事是，千真万确，喷气背包是真实存在的。美国科学家在60年代确实研制出了一个，而且效果相当不错。50年前，杂志上到处都是这样的说法：不久之后，每个车库里都会有一个喷气背包。喷气背包似乎代表了未来。不仅仅是我和大卫一直痴迷于寻找喷气背包。几十年来，科学家们，许多人一直试图将喷气背包变成现实。那么发生了什么？为什么喷气背包会淡出我们的视线？自从人类梦想着违背上帝的意愿在空中飞行以来，我们就一直渴望
jetpacks. A Russian scientist came up with a drawing for one in the 1910s, but it was never built. Jetpacks showed up in pop culture a few decades later, in things like Buck Rogers comics in the 1930s, well before they became a reality. By mid-century, they came to represent the whole idea of a futuristic society, alongside flying cars and servant robots. The Jetsons was, you know, I would watch it on Saturday mornings as the cartoons then, and so that was my sense of, you know, space travel.
拥有喷气背包。一个俄国科学家在2010年代画出过一张设计图，但从未被建造出来。几十年后，喷气背包出现在流行文化中，比如20世纪30年代的《巴克·罗杰斯》漫画，远在它们成为现实之前。到了本世纪中叶，它们开始代表整个未来主义社会的理念，与飞行汽车和机器人仆人并驾齐驱。《杰特逊一家》是，你知道的，我会在周六早上的动画片时间看它，所以那就是我对，你知道的，太空旅行的理解。
There was jet packs in the Jetsons. And so that got linked to this memory. Let's go George, up, up and away. Yeah, but not too high, my ears will pop. Jet packs may have been the stuff of cartoons, but scientists weren't far behind. You might be thinking of a classic jet pack, like a backpack with flames coming out of the bottom, but it took a while to get there.
《杰特逊一家》里有喷气背包。于是这与这段记忆联系在了一起。我们走吧，乔治，飞向高空。是的，但别太高，我的耳朵会受不了的。喷气背包可能只是动画片里的东西，但科学家们并没有落后太远。你可能会想到经典的喷气背包，比如底部喷射着火焰的双肩包，但要做到这一点花了一些时间。
Other technologies were tried out first, like flying shoes with propellers on the bottom, or a platform that could be lifted by compressed air. None of these baubles really panned out until the military got involved. A lot of the cutting edge technology, sadly, is developed by the military because, number one, the military's got deep pockets, they got money to spend on this stuff. Steve Lado is the author of the book, The Great American Jetpack. Anything that can give you an advantage in war is something your military wants. So people were thinking, hey, if we could strap rockets to soldiers who are running across a field, if it made them run faster, it'd be harder to shoot, they'd get farther, that kind of thing. In the 1950s, the U.S. military took
人们首先尝试了其他技术，比如底部带螺旋桨的飞行鞋，或者可以通过压缩空气升空的平台。直到军方介入，这些小玩意儿才真正取得突破。遗憾的是，许多尖端技术都是由军方开发的，因为第一，军方财大气粗，他们有钱在这上面挥霍。史蒂夫·拉多是《伟大的美国喷气背包》一书的作者。任何能在战争中为你提供优势的东西都是你军队想要的东西。所以人们在想，嘿，如果我们能把火箭绑在穿梭于战场上的士兵身上，如果能让他们跑得更快，就更难被击中，他们就能走得更远，诸如此类。20世纪50年代，美国军方对
a serious interest in jetpack research. This was a very tense period of the Cold War. That's Colleen Anderson. She's a rocketry expert at the Smithsonian. I think it speaks to the fears of the Cold War. That's Colleen Anderson. She's a rocketry expert at the Smithsonian. I think it speaks to the fears of the Cold War, the kind of unknown aspects of the Cold War, and if the Cold War would become a hot war, what tools would be needed to fight? The military kicked it out to the regular contractors to see if anybody wanted to build
喷气背包的研究产生了浓厚的兴趣。这是冷战时期一个非常紧张的时期。这是科琳·安德森。她是史密森尼学会的火箭专家。我认为这反映了对冷战的恐惧。这是科琳·安德森。她是史密森尼学会的火箭专家。我认为这反映了对冷战的恐惧，对冷战未知方面的担忧，以及如果冷战变成热战，需要什么工具来战斗？军方将这个项目交给了常规承包商，看有没有人想建造
a jetpack. Multiple aerospace companies came up with prototypes. None of these quite hit the mark. Until the Bell Aircraft Corporation entered the fray. They had a division called Bell Aerospace that focused on jets and rockets. In the race to make a jetpack, Bell had one giant advantage over their rivals, an engineer named Wendell Moore. Wendell Moore, how do I put this?
一个喷气背包。多家航空航天公司都拿出了原型机。这些都没有完全达到目标。直到贝尔飞机公司加入战局。他们有一个名为贝尔航空航天的部门，专注于喷气机和火箭。在制造喷气背包的竞赛中，贝尔公司比竞争对手有一个巨大的优势，那就是一位名叫温德尔·摩尔的工程师。温德尔·摩尔，我该怎么说呢？
He looked exactly what you think a 1950s aerospace engineer would look like. He had a flat top haircut and these big thick glasses and a neat little bow tie. But beneath his square exterior, Wendell Moore was eccentric and talented enough to build his own experimental plane… in his suburban garage. This is Bill Souter. He worked for Moore at Bell Aerospace. space. The ascender, or the ascender, is the pronunciation they would use.
他的外表完全符合你对20世纪50年代航空航天工程师的想象。他留着平头，戴着厚厚的大眼镜，系着一个整洁的小领结。但在他刻板的外表下，温德尔·摩尔却非常古怪，而且才华横溢，足以在郊区的车库里……造出他自己的实验飞机。这是比尔·苏特。他曾在贝尔航空航天公司为摩尔工作。空间。升力机，或者叫升力机，这是他们使用的发音。
It was a rear propeller, rear engine, airplane, experimental. You know, we used to get the biggest kick out of it. At Bell, Moore developed rocket thrusters to help jet planes change direction at high altitude. So when the military called and asked about jet packs, Wendell Moore didn't have to look far for inspiration. And Wendell Moore was looking at him one day and said, you know, if we made those little rocket thrusters a little bigger and strapped them to a person, maybe he could get off the ground. In the mid-1950s, Wendell Moore drew up a design for a device he called the Rocket Belt. Moore's design looked a lot more like the jet packs
那是一架后置螺旋桨、后置发动机的实验飞机。你知道的，我们以前总是从中获得最大的乐趣。在贝尔，摩尔开发了火箭推进器，帮助喷气式飞机在高空改变方向。因此，当军方打电话询问喷气背包时，温德尔·摩尔并不需要费力去寻找灵感。温德尔·摩尔有一天看着他说道，你知道的，如果我们把那些小火箭推进器做大一点，把它们绑在人身上，也许他就能离地而起了。20世纪50年代中期，温德尔·摩尔设计了一种他称之为“火箭腰带”的装置。摩尔的设计看起来更像卡通和漫画书里的
from cartoons and comic books. The Rocket Belt, it has a harness or a vest that you would put over the shoulders, and then it has tanks for the propellants, and then the exhaust would come out. The Rocket Belt included two arms the pilot could hold onto, and to propel the device, Bell Aerospace
喷气背包。火箭腰带有一个可以套在肩膀上的背带或背心，然后有推进剂储罐，接着废气会喷射出来。火箭腰带包括两个供飞行员抓握的手臂，为了推进该装置，贝尔航空航天公司
would fill the tanks with one of the most dangerous substances on Earth, highly concentrated hydrogen peroxide. So you can go to a drug store and buy hydrogen peroxide and use it to clean cuts and take things off, you know, and clean with and whatever. But that's a very, very low percentage of hydrogen peroxide, like 3% solution. If it's closer to 90 or 95%,
会在储罐里装满地球上最危险的物质之一——高浓度过氧化氢。所以你可以去药店买过氧化氢，用来清洗伤口、去除污渍什么的。但这是一种浓度非常非常低的过氧化氢，大约是3%的溶液。如果接近90%或95%，
it's actually extremely volatile. The Bell design was elegant in its simplicity. On the metal arms, there was a throttle, like you'd see on a motorcycle. And when you twisted the throttle, it would cause this violent chemical reaction. The powerful reaction would create steam that was so strong, it could propel a human being
它其实极其不稳定。贝尔的设计在简洁性上堪称优雅。在金属手臂上有一个油门，就像你在摩托车上看到的那样。当你扭动油门时，它会引发剧烈的化学反应。强烈的反应会产生威力巨大的蒸汽，能够将人类推向
through the air. The rocket belt was designed to be kinesthetic, which means that pilots could pivot their body to move the belt backwards and forwards. The idea that you can control something through your body movements in an obvious manner, you know, like you lean the direction you want to go. We've all heard of like the Segway scooters. The Segway scooter was supposed to be that you could get on it and use it almost instantly without thinking about it.
空中。火箭腰带被设计成动觉式的，这意味着飞行员可以通过移动身体来使腰带前后移动。你可以通过身体动作以一种显而易见的方式控制某些东西的理念，你知道的，就像你向你想去的方向倾斜身体。我们都听说过赛格威滑板车。赛格威滑板车的本意是你踩上去就能用，几乎不需要思考。
Wendell Moore said, you know, I think if we actually put this thing on your back and put the nozzles in the right place, in the right direction, we could get this thing to fly the direction you want it to go by simply leaning, or leaning this way, you go that way. The Rocket Belt was a sci-fi dream come to life. But to be clear, the rocket belt wasn't a jetpack
温德尔·摩尔说，你知道的，我想如果我们真的把这东西绑在你的背上，把喷嘴放在合适的位置和方向，我们就能通过简单的倾斜，让这东西朝着你希望的方向飞行，向这边倾斜，你就去那边。火箭腰带是化为现实的科幻梦想。但要明确的是，从严格意义上讲，火箭腰带并不是喷气背包，
technically speaking, because it didn't use a jet engine. Instead, it was powered by steam. But still, even back then, lots of people used the words jetpack and rocket belt interchangeably. Because, I mean, it just kinda seemed like a jetpack. With funding from the military, inventor Wendell Moore completed his first prototype for his design in 1960. The next step was to actually fly that sucker. Moore set up an indoor test rig at the Bell Aerospace Office in Niagara Falls. The office had an old airplane hangar, so there was lots of room for flights. In an act of either bravery or incredible stupidity,
因为它没有使用喷气发动机。相反，它是靠蒸汽驱动的。不过即便在当年，许多人还是混用了“喷气背包”和“火箭腰带”这两个词。因为，我的意思是，它看起来就有点像个喷气背包。在军方的资助下，发明家温德尔·摩尔于1960年完成了他的第一款设计原型。下一步就是真正试飞这个家伙。摩尔在尼亚加拉瀑布的贝尔航空航天办公室搭建了一个室内测试架。办公室里有一个旧飞机机库，所以有充足的飞行空间。出于勇敢或是难以置信的愚蠢，
Wendell Moore nominated himself as the first test pilot. Wendell Moore would drive to work, strap on the rocket belt, twist the throttle, and up he'd go. He would take it up a couple feet, and then a couple more. The rocket belt was heavy. It weighed over 100 pounds. It was noisy too, creating a sound many people compared to a jackhammer.
温德尔·摩尔自荐担任第一位试飞员。温德尔·摩尔会开车上班，绑上火箭腰带，扭动油门，然后他就会升空。他会把它升空几英尺，然后再升几英尺。火箭腰带很重。它重达100多磅。它也很吵，发出的声音让许多人将其比作手提钻。
And it was really hot, with steam reaching over 1300 degrees Fahrenheit. Despite all of these inconvenient features, the rocket belt worked. Wendell Moore was doing the impossible. He was the first person ever to fly a rocket belt. He was also the first person ever to fall while using a rocket belt. Here's Bill Souter. They had a nylon rope for the safety tether, melted the rope, and he dropped to the floor broke his knee so and that's when when Bell told him more you're done flying. Despite this incident the program kept going and the first true rocket belt flight without tethers
而且它真的很热，蒸汽温度达到华氏1300多度。尽管有所有这些不便的特点，火箭腰带还是成功了。温德尔·摩尔在创造不可能。他是历史上第一个驾驶火箭腰带飞行的人。他也是历史上第一个在使用火箭腰带时摔倒的人。这是比尔·苏特。他们有一根用作安全绳的尼龙绳，（蒸汽）融化了这根绳子，他掉到了地板上，摔断了膝盖，然后就在那时，贝尔告诉摩尔，你别想再飞了。尽管发生了这次事故，项目仍在继续，第一次真正意义上的无束缚火箭腰带飞行
happened on April 20th 1961 with a pilot named Hal Graham. The flight was momentous, but also kind of small. Graham bent his knees and he pushed up, and suddenly in this big cloud of steam, Hal Graham was in the air. Then just as quickly as he was up there, he started to come down, and hit the grass with this kind of running tumble. We couldn't talk to Hal Graham for this story because he died in 2009, but he did record a song about his time as a rocket belt pilot that you can find on YouTube. The team is fleeting fast. The task before you people is to groove up on the path. Howe Graham did several flights on the rocket belt, including a demonstration for the president.
发生在1961年4月20日，飞行员名叫哈尔·格雷姆。这次飞行意义重大，但也有点小。格雷姆弯下膝盖向上推，突然在一大团蒸汽中，哈尔·格雷姆飞上了天空。然后，就像他上去时一样快，他开始下降，以一种跑着滚翻的姿态撞上了草坪。我们无法就这个故事采访哈尔·格雷姆，因为他在2009年去世了，但他确实录制了一首关于他作为火箭腰带飞行员时光的歌曲，你可以在YouTube上找到它。团队正在飞速流逝。摆在你们面前的任务是融入这条道路。哈尔·格雷姆用火箭腰带进行了多次飞行，包括为总统进行了一场演示。
Graham flew the rocket belt in front of JFK, who was said to be slack-jawed as he watched a man gliding through the air. Bell Aerospace was eager to promote their new invention. The company had an art department that created drawings that showed the rocket belt out in the world. Their work imagined a society with office workers and American soldiers using rocket belts.
格雷姆在肯尼迪总统面前驾驶着火箭腰带飞行，据说肯尼迪目睹一个男人在空中滑翔时，惊讶得合不拢嘴。贝尔航空航天公司急于推广他们的新发明。该公司有一个艺术部门，创作了展示火箭腰带在现实世界中应用的画作。他们的作品想象了一个由办公室职员和美国士兵使用火箭腰带的社会。
Okay, so here's actually a guy in like an army uniform. Yep. Yeah. He's got the requisite serious expression on his face for going into battle. Don Irwin is the president of the board at the Niagara Aerospace Museum, which has copies of many of these drawings. In one drawing, a fleet of US soldiers are marching on, guns in hand, rocket belts carelessly flung over their backs.
好吧，这里实际上有一个穿着军服的家伙。是的。是的。他脸上带着一副去打仗时必不可少的严肃表情。唐·欧文是尼亚加拉航空航天博物馆的董事会主席，该博物馆收藏了许多此类画作的复印件。在其中一幅画中，一队美国士兵正在行进，手持枪械，火箭腰带漫不经心地挂在背上。
This is an artist's rendering of how the rocket belt might be used, and on half the panel we see an infantryman wearing the rocket belt with his helmet and fatigues on. And in the background, some of his buddies are scaling a cliff, right? So you can see where they were thinking in conventional warfare. The media was paying attention. Magazines ran articles about the potential uses for the new flying machine from military applications like saving people trapped in a war zone to everyday uses like delivering the mail. Wenzel Moore told Popular Science Magazine the rocket belt would be publicly available within two to three years, even though there wasn't really a plan for that to happen.
这是艺术家对火箭腰带如何被使用的渲染图，在画面的一半，我们可以看到一个步兵穿着火箭腰带，戴着头盔，穿着作训服。在背景中，他的一些同伴正在攀爬悬崖，对吧？所以你可以看出他们在传统战争中的设想。媒体正在给予关注。各杂志刊登了关于这种新型飞行机器潜在用途的文章，从拯救被困在战区的人等军事应用，到送信等日常用途。温泽尔·摩尔告诉《大众科学》杂志，火箭腰带将在两到三年内向公众开放，尽管当时并没有真正实现这一目标的计划。
The rocket belt was a long way from being deployed in a war zone, let alone showing up in every driveway. In fact, testing was starting to turn up some pretty serious limitations, the main one being flight duration. It's extremely heavy for one person to have to carry themselves, and this 50 pounds of this hydrogen peroxide propellant only works for about 20 seconds. And they're like, okay, can we extend that? And they're like, probably not by much. If the idea of the rocket belt was to get soldiers out of danger, 20 seconds wasn't gonna buy a whole lot of time,
火箭腰带距离在战区部署还有很长的路要走，更不用说出现在每个车库的门前了。事实上，测试开始暴露出一些相当严重的局限性，最主要的一个就是飞行持续时间。一个人背着自己飞行极其沉重，这50磅的过氧化氢推进剂只能维持大约20秒。他们会想，好吧，我们能延长这个时间吗？而他们的回答是：大概延长不了多少。如果火箭腰带的目的是让士兵脱离危险，20秒可买不到多少时间，
especially when the weight of the pack itself would slow soldiers down. You also couldn't really use it for search and rescue because you needed the arms to steer, so your hands would be busy, you couldn't really pick anybody up. Practically, it just didn't make a lot of sense. The military decided to pull funding,
特别是当背包本身的重量会拖慢士兵的速度时。你也无法真正用它来进行搜救，因为你需要双手来操纵，所以你的双手会很忙，你实际上无法抱起任何人。从实用角度来看，这根本说不通。军方决定撤资，
and this very well could have spelled the end for Bell's rocket belt program But Bell wasn't ready to give up and they decided to try one last thing to capture the public's attention and bring the rocket belt To the next level to keep the dream alive Bell aerospace decided to take the rocket belt on the road People were really excited after reading about it in newspapers and magazines. And now they actually wanted to see the thing in action. So Bell hired a promoter with experience on the county fair circuit to book a series of public demonstrations. To pull off these spectacular public demos, they were going to need more pilots,
这很可能宣告贝尔火箭腰带项目的终结，但贝尔并没有准备放弃，他们决定尝试最后一件事，以吸引公众的注意力，并将火箭腰带推向一个新的水平。为了让梦想延续，贝尔航空航天公司决定带着火箭腰带进行巡回演出。人们在报纸和杂志上读到它之后感到非常兴奋。现在他们真的想亲眼看到这东西大显身手。于是贝尔雇佣了一个有乡村集市巡回路演经验的推广人，来预定一系列的公众演示。为了完成这些壮观的公开演示，他们需要更多的飞行员，
somebody young and stupid enough to fly this thing. I was young and stupid, and fly this thing. I was young and stupid. And that's the way they wanted you. Don't ask any questions, kid. Just get in there. We'll tighten it up. Remember, this is Bill Suter from Bell Aerospace. Before he worked there, he was actually Wendell Moore's neighbor growing up. And when Bill was just 19 years old, he became, I would say,
需要足够年轻且愚蠢到敢开这玩意儿的人。我当时又年轻又愚蠢，而且敢开这玩意儿。我当时又年轻又愚蠢。他们就是想要这样的人。别问任何问题，孩子。进去就行了。我们会帮你绑紧的。记住，这是来自贝尔航空航天公司的比尔·苏特。在他去那儿工作之前，他其实是温德尔·摩尔从小到大的邻居。当比尔只有19岁时，我可以说，
understandably curious about the rocket belt. I was pestering him all the time, you know, I want to fly that thing, I want to fly that thing. Bill didn't have much work experience, other than, you know, cutting Wendell Moore's lawn. But that did not stop Wendell from recruiting Bill Souter to become a rocket belt pilot. Nepotism is a wonderful thing. Wendell Moore wanted to show that pretty much anyone could strap on the rocket belt and make it work. If Bill could do it, then surely, say, an American soldier could do it too.
他对火箭腰带产生了理所当然的好奇心。我一直在纠缠他，你知道的，我想开那玩意儿，我想开那玩意儿。比尔没有什么工作经验，除了，你知道的，给温德尔·摩尔修剪草坪。但这并没有阻止温德尔招募比尔·苏特成为一名火箭腰带飞行员。任人唯亲是一件美好的事。温德尔·摩尔想证明几乎任何人都可以绑上火箭腰带并让它运转起来。如果比尔能做到，那么当然，比如一个美国士兵也能做到。
In 1964, Bill started testing the rocket belt, doing tethered flights at the Bell office. The first thing he noticed about the rocket belt was the intense noise it made. It was 130 decibels. The helmet was padded, you know, for sound and all, but I'm wearing ear-fra- hearing aids nowadays. I don't think it's from that. I think it might have been from the jet pack. By this point, the rocket belt could still only fly about 21 seconds, which to be fair, can feel like a long time when you have a rocket strapped to your back. If you watch a sweep hand on your watch or a clock or something, 21 seconds is a long time. To have a 800 to 1000 horsepower rocket strapped to your back, it can be an eternity.
1964年，比尔开始测试火箭腰带，在贝尔办公室进行系留飞行。他对火箭腰带的第一个印象就是它发出的巨大噪音。那是130分贝。头盔是加了衬垫的，你知道的，为了隔音什么的，但我现在戴着助听器。我不认为这是因为那个。我觉得可能是因为那个喷气背包。到这个时候，火箭腰带仍然只能飞行大约21秒，公平地说，当你的背上绑着一个火箭时，这感觉可能会很漫长。如果你看着手表或时钟上的秒针之类的东西，21秒是很长的一段时间。背上绑着一个800到1000马力的火箭，这可能就像永恒一样漫长。
When things start going wrong, they go wrong real fast. You know, we used to, we used to have a phrase, it's the grass in your ass. The thing about a 21 second flight is that the rocket belt was going to stop working after 21 seconds, even if the pilot was still in the air. To make sure the rocket belt pilots didn't wipe out midair, Bell developed a special helmet with a built-in warning system. It was a vibrator, mind your business now. It was a vibrator that fit against the back of your skull
当事情开始出错时，它们会以极快的速度出错。你知道的，我们以前，我们以前有一句俗语，就是“屁股着地”。21秒飞行的关键在于，即使飞行员还在空中，火箭腰带也会在21秒后停止工作。为了确保火箭腰带飞行员不会在空中坠毁，贝尔开发了一种带有内置预警系统的特殊头盔。那是一个震动器，现在管好你自己的事吧。那是一个贴在你的头骨后方的震动器，
because they tried lights and everything as warning system and the mental overload, they ended up with the vibrator on the skull. You can't ignore it. Your teeth vibrate. So at 10 seconds you get a buzz and then you get one every second for five seconds. Now you're at 15 laps time, you got six seconds left. So get your affairs in order.
因为他们尝试过灯光等各种东西作为预警系统，却导致了精神超载，最后他们选定了头骨上的震动器。你无法忽视它。你的牙齿都会震动。所以在第10秒你会得到一个蜂鸣声，然后接下来的五秒内每秒都会响一次。现在你的时间到了15秒，你还剩6秒。所以赶快把你的后事安排好吧。
Granted, the helmet didn't solve all possible safety problems, Bill Suter remembers his first bad test on the rocket pelt. I rose up the flight plan was to go straight up 20-25 feet inside the hangar and then move forward and stop turn around come back and land. I rose up when I'm about 25 feet up, I put it in the hover position and the throttle handle came off in my hand. Thanks to the safety tether, everything turned out okay and Bill wasn't hurt. But this is the kind of accident
当然，头盔并没有解决所有可能的安全问题，比尔·苏特还记得他在火箭腰带上的第一次糟糕测试。我升空了，飞行计划是在机库内笔直上升20-25英尺，然后向前移动并停下来，转身返回并降落。我升了上去，当我在大约25英尺高的地方时，我把它放在悬停位置，油门手柄却在我的手中脱落了。多亏了安全绳，一切都安然无恙，比尔也没有受伤。但这就是那种
that would turn off certain people, people like me, from the idea of a rocket belt. But not Bill Souter, he loved the challenge. He says he got the hang of it quickly and the controls, they felt like ice skating. He developed this rhythm with the belt that he called body English. After his training was complete,
会让某些人——比如我——对火箭腰带望而却步的事故。但比尔·苏特没有，他热爱这种挑战。他说他很快就掌握了窍门，操控感感觉就像滑冰一样。他用腰带发展出了一种他称之为“身体英语”的节奏。他的训练完成后，
Bell Aerospace decided Bill Suter was ready to show the world what the rocket belt was capable of. So he packed his bags and shipped out to glamorous Sacramento, California. Miss Teenage USA or something like that to do with some national contest every year, wanted to know if Belle could bring the rocket belt to display it here at the teenage fair or whatever it was. It was the first time I'd ever seen the ocean or I'd never been out of Youngstown." Bill Souter had never been on an airplane before. He'd never even stayed in a hotel. And he certainly hadn't flown a rocket belt over a crowd of thousands of cheering spectators under a spotlight at night. Well the light from the outside fairgrounds made it like twilight.
贝尔航空航天公司决定比尔·苏特已经准备好向世界展示火箭腰带的实力了。于是他收拾行李，出发前往迷人的加利福尼亚州萨克拉门托。全美青少年小姐或者类似与每年全国选美大赛有关的活动，想知道贝尔是否可以把火箭腰带带到这里，在青少年集市还是什么活动上展示。那是我第一次见到大海，我以前从未离开过扬斯敦。”比尔·苏特以前从未坐过飞机。他甚至从未住过酒店。他当然也没有在夜晚的聚光灯下，在数千名欢呼观众的人海上方驾驶过火箭腰带。好吧，外面集市广场的光线使它看起来像黄昏。
Well, it was darker than twilight, but then they wanted all the lights in the racetrack. It was supposed to be a surprise. That's a fart with a lump in it. It certainly was a surprise and this brilliant bright big spotlights right on me. I said, that light's blinding me. I gotta get that out of my eyes. Just before the flight, the lights went down. For this trick to work, Bill had to fly just over the crowd, close enough they could see him and the rocket belt, and then make a very careful landing on a narrow stage.
好吧，它比黄昏还要暗，但随后他们想要赛马场里的所有灯光。这本该是个惊喜。那简直是一个带有一块硬块的屁。这确实是个惊喜，明亮耀眼的聚光灯直接照在我身上。我说，这光快把我弄瞎了。我得把它从我眼前弄开。就在飞行前，灯光暗了下来。为了让这个把戏成功，比尔必须刚好在人群上方飞行，近到他们能看到他和火箭腰带，然后在一个狭窄的舞台上非常小心地降落。
So on cue, I take off and I'm to fly down the racetrack, the grandstand is behind here. Well, nobody had warned the orchestra, which was in the orchestra pit, of what was about to happen. And I'm coming in, I'm coming down as I'm coming in. Below me there's a blizzard, sheet music. And all I see is assholes in the elbows of the musicians climbing over. They don't know what was happening. They're panic stricken.
所以听到暗号，我起飞了，我要沿着赛马场飞，看台就在后面。好吧，没有人警告管弦乐队，也就是乐池里的乐队，接下来会发生什么。我飞了过来，随着我过来，我正在下降。在我下方是一场暴风雪，那是乐谱。我看到的只有音乐家们爬来爬去的肘部里露出的屁股。他们不知道发生了什么。他们惊恐万状。
I'm distracted by that. Somehow, despite all that, Bill managed to touch down and land on the stage, and nobody got hurt. The crowd might have stood up and cheered in rapturous applause. Bill Souter was just happy to pull it off. Did you feel like relief when that happened?
我被那分散了注意力。不知何故，尽管经历了这一切，比尔还是设法降落在了舞台上，没有人受伤。观众可能起立并报以狂热的掌声欢呼。比尔·苏特只是很高兴能成功完成。当这一切发生时，你感到了解脱吗？
Oh, man. Yeah. And almost every flight I've ever made is relief. That was my introduction to showbiz. After the first flight, Bill kept showing off the rocket belt at the Sacramento Fair. Every day, three times a day, for ten more days. People loved it. Then Bill started sending him farther afield.
哦，天哪。是的。我做过的几乎每一次飞行都是一种解脱。那是我的演艺界初体验。第一次飞行后，比尔继续在萨克拉门托集市上展示火箭腰带。每天三次，连续十天。人们太喜欢它了。接着比尔开始派他去更远的地方。
He toured the country making $147 a week. And then we went to, I think it was Las Vegas, to fly over the Flamingo Hotel swimming pool, the Los Angeles county fair, and then up to Seattle to Mount Billingham, Washington. He flew in the first Super Bowl, which, okay, the first Super Bowl wasn't a big deal yet, but still, the Super Bowl. We're just looking through pictures of the rocket belt in different scenarios. This one's flying next to a Navy ship. This one is at Disneyland in front of the castle.
他在全国各地巡演，每周赚147美元。然后我们去了，我想那是拉斯维加斯，飞过火烈鸟酒店的游泳池，洛杉矶县集市，然后去西雅图到华盛顿州的灵汉姆山。他参加了第一届超级碗，好吧，虽然第一届超级碗当时还不是什么大不了的事，但不管怎样，那是超级碗。我们正在翻看不同场景下火箭腰带的照片。这张是飞在一艘海军军舰旁边。这张是在迪士尼乐园的城堡前面。
Here's Don Irwin of the Niagara Aerospace Museum, which has hundreds of photos of the rocket belt in action. They demonstrate a lot by flying over things. And what I like about this picture is you can see they're flying over an airplane. Here's a shadow dangerously close to the airplane itself. So he's either demonstrating how easy it is to control and detail, or he's out of control. Bell did a great job keeping the rocket belt in the public eye. Here's Steve Leto.
这是尼亚加拉航空航天博物馆的唐·欧文，该博物馆拥有数百张火箭腰带投入使用的照片。他们通过在物体上方飞行来做大量演示。我喜欢这张照片的原因是你可以看到他们正飞过一架飞机。这里有一个阴影，距离飞机本身危险地近。所以他要么是在展示它的控制和细节是多么容易，要么就是他失控了。贝尔在让火箭腰带保持在公众视线方面做得非常出色。这是史蒂夫·拉多。
They made a concerted effort to get these things into the media, not just in front of newspaper reporters, but on camera, on television. So there's an episode of Gilligan's Island, where Gilligan finds a jet pack. Good heavens, look what you've made me do. Sorry, professor, but we're dying to find out if this jet pack is gonna be able to fly to Hawaii. Well, there's a chance, Skipper, but... Oh, did you hear that, Gilligan?
他们齐心协力让这些东西进入媒体，不仅是在报纸记者面前，而且是通过镜头、在电视上。所以有一集《吉利根岛》，吉利根在岛上发现了一个喷气背包。天哪，看看你让我做了什么。对不起，教授，但我们极想知道这个喷气背包是否能飞到夏威夷。嗯，有机会，船长，但是……哦，你听到了吗，吉利根？
One of us might be able to fly to Hawaii. Isn't that great news? In 1965, the Rocket Belt had its biggest break. Bill got the call to appear in the James Bond movie Thunderball. The producers had an idea for a stunt, where James Bond is being chased around this French villa, and he'll climb up to the roof and then casually ride a jetpack all the way down to a waiting Aston Martin. Of course, it was too dangerous to put Sean Connery on a rocket belt, so Bill and a colleague named Gordy Yeager were picked as his stunt doubles. When Bill and Gordy got to France for filming, the producers had a surprise.
我们中的一个人也许能飞到夏威夷。这不是个好消息吗？1965年，火箭腰带迎来了它最大的突破。比尔接到电话，要在詹姆斯·邦德电影《霹雳弹》中出镜。制片人有一个特技点子：詹姆斯·邦德在一个法国别墅周围被追赶，他会爬上屋顶，然后大摇大摆地骑着喷气背包一路下降到一辆等候着的阿斯顿·马丁旁边。当然，让肖恩·康纳利坐上火箭腰带太危险了，所以比尔和一位名叫戈迪·耶格尔的同事被选中担任他的替身。当比尔和戈迪到达法国进行拍摄时，制片人给他们准备了一个惊喜。
In their opinion, James Bond wouldn't wear a helmet while flying a jetpack, a prospect that was way too dangerous for Bill's suitor. But the producers tried to make him do it anyway. The first thing they do is try bribing us with money. Just this once. Just, you know, that wouldn't work. So they got some brown shoe polish somewhere. They tried to make it look like hair? Well, just get it brown, you know? The crew had to go back and do reshoots to make everything work, but in the final sequence,
在他们看来，詹姆斯·邦德在驾驶喷气背包时是不会戴头盔的，这对于比尔·苏特来说实在是太危险了。但制片人们还是试图强迫他这么做。他们做的第一件事就是试图用钱收买我们。就这一次。只是，你知道的，那不管用。于是他们不知从哪弄来了一些棕色的鞋油。他们试图让它看起来像头发？好吧，就是把它弄成棕色，你知道的？剧组不得不回去进行补拍来让一切顺利进行，但在最后的序列中，
Connery straps on the jet pack, yes, wearing a helmet, and escapes some pesky goons, soaring over a French castle and landing next to a luxury car. Then Connery delivers an iconic line about the rocket belt. for a French castle and landing next to a luxury car. Then Connery delivers an iconic line about the rocket belt. No well-dressed man should be without one. No well-dressed man should be without one. Yes, very practical.
康纳利绑上了喷气背包，是的，戴着头盔，摆脱了一些讨厌的打手，翱翔过一座法国城堡并降落在一辆豪华汽车旁。然后康纳利说了一句关于火箭腰带的经典台词。过一座法国城堡并降落在一辆豪华汽车旁。然后康纳利说了一句关于火箭腰带的经典台词。任何衣着得体的男人都不能没有它。任何衣着得体的男人都不能没有它。是的，非常实用。
By the mid-60s, things were going really well with the rocket belt, but there was a gap between reality and the public dream of a jetpack in every driveway. A year went by, and then another, but the rocket belt didn't feel any closer to being available to the public. Here's Steve Lado. There was a bit of over-promising going on. Newspaper reporters would say, these things are on the horizon, we've got one doing this now, and pretty soon we'll be doing that. And we don't know where that stretch came from, but it got into the culture that pretty soon we're all going to have them.
到60年代中期，火箭腰带的发展非常顺利，但现实与公众梦想的“每个车库里都有一个喷气背包”之间仍有差距。一年又一年过去了，但火箭腰带并没有让人感觉离向公众开放更近一步。这是史蒂夫·拉多。当时存在一点过度承诺的情况。报纸记者会说，这些东西指日可待，我们现在有一个正在做这个，很快我们就会做那个。我们不知道这种夸大是从哪里来的，但它已经融入了文化中，认为很快我们所有人都会拥有它们。
We were promised jetpacks. We were. We were. Bill Suter says the media got carried away when they talked about the rocket belt. By the late 1960s, in the public imagination, the novelty started wearing off. Millions of people had seen the rocket belt, but it didn't have any new tricks. Even Bill Souter started getting tired of it. Did it ever get routine? Yeah, it did.
我们被许诺过有喷气背包。我们确实被许诺过。比尔·苏特说，媒体在谈论火箭腰带时有点忘乎所以了。到了20世纪60年代末，在公众的想象中，新鲜感开始消退。数百万人见过火箭腰带，但它并没有什么新把戏。甚至比尔·苏特也开始对它感到厌倦。这变得成例行公事了吗？是的，确实如此。
And once I got married and started a family, it wasn't fun anymore. Bill flew the rocket belt for five years, in 12 countries and 42 states. But by the late 1960s, Bill and his wife Cheryl had kids. And every time he landed the rocket belt and felt that little pang of relief,
一旦我结婚并组建了家庭，它就不再有趣了。比尔驾驶火箭腰带飞行了五年，走过了12个国家和42个州。但到了20世纪60年代末，比尔和他的妻子谢丽尔有了孩子。而且每次他降落火箭腰带并感受到那种小小的解脱感时，
he wanted to be back home. And it was becoming obvious the military wasn't going to bail out the program by ordering a giant fleet of these things. The handwriting was on the wall. Lyndon Johnson, he cut the space program to, you know, his great society. You know, he had to use his money for social programs. Not that there's anything wrong with that, but science needs it too.
他都想回到家中。而且情况越来越明显，军方不会通过订购一大批这东西来拯救这个程序。大势已趋。林登·约翰逊，他削减了太空计划来资助，你知道的，他的伟大社会计划。你知道的，他必须把钱用在社会计划上。并不是说这有什么不对，但科学也需要它。
Anyway, there's no way we're going to continue with the jet belt. Bill flew the rocket belt at the New York State Fair in 1969. The emcee noticed that Bill was standing next to the governor, and he told the audience to welcome Mr. Rockefeller and Mr. Rockefeller. After that, Bell Aerospace wrapped up the program. Wendell Moore, the inventor, developed a prototype for a jet belt powered by kerosene, and he got to see it fly without tethers one time,
无论如何，我们不可能继续制造喷气腰带了。比尔于1969年在纽约州博览会上驾驶了火箭腰带。司仪注意到比尔正站在州长旁边，他告诉观众欢迎洛克菲勒先生和洛克菲勒先生。在那之后，贝尔航空航天公司结束了这个项目。发明家温德尔·摩尔开发了一个由煤油驱动的喷气腰带原型机，并且他在1969年因心脏病突发突然去世之前，
before he died suddenly of a heart attack in 1969. Bell Aerospace gave away their rocket belt prototypes to the Smithsonian and other schools and museums and with nothing to do Bill Souter left the company. Bill ended up taking a new job at the State Power Authority in Niagara Falls, New York. There he wowed coworkers with stories of traveling the world. Co-workers like my dad Roger. Bill Souter, he's the jetpack guy. He's the one I'd always heard about.
亲眼看到它无束缚飞行了一次。贝尔航空航天公司把他们的火箭腰带原型机送给了史密森尼学会以及其他学校和博物馆，无事可做的比尔·苏特离开了公司。比尔最终在纽约州尼亚加拉瀑布的国家电力局找到了一份新工作。在那里，他用周游世界的经历惊艳了同事们。比如像我爸爸罗杰这样的同事。比尔·苏特，他就是那个喷气背包男。他就是我一直听说的那个人。
Bill doesn't remember my dad. Probably because, you know, my dad didn't have a jetpack. Bill may have left Bell Aerospace, but he didn't give up on jetpacks. Over the years, inspired by the rocket belt, various hobbyists have built their own, and they called Bill Souter for help with test flights and public demonstrations. Bill's last big ride was over the 1984 Olympic Opening Ceremonies, an event that was watched by the entire world. 2.5 billion people. That's what I said to myself. I'm standing up there and my father died years before that. When I'm telling my father, well, you know, in my mind I'm telling him, look at this, look at this. Did you ever think it would come to this? Over the years, jet packs have come a long way. Flight times are longer. Some designs today are actually built
比尔不记得我爸爸了。可能是因为，你知道的，我爸爸没有喷气背包。比尔可能离开了贝尔航空航天公司，但他并没有放弃喷气背包。多年来，受火箭腰带的启发，各路业余爱好者建造了自己的喷气背包，他们打电话给比尔·苏特寻求试飞和公开演示方面的帮助。比尔最后一次大型飞行是在1984年奥运会开幕式上，这是一场全世界都在观看的盛事。25亿人。这就是我当时对自己的说的。我站在那里，而我父亲在那之前好几年就去世了。当我告诉我父亲时，嗯，你知道的，在我的脑海里我告诉他，看这个，看这个。你曾想过会变成这样吗？多年来，喷气背包已经取得了长足的进步。飞行时间更长了。如今的一些设计实际上是用
with small jet engines instead of hydrogen peroxide tanks. So we finally have real literal jet packs. But the reality is people aren't as enthusiastic. There's a jet pack pilot named David Maimon who lives in Australia. And a couple of years ago, he flew his machine over the Sydney harbour. The footage is quite something but in an interview with The Guardian Maimon said he was surprised by the reaction. Here's
小型喷气发动机代替了过氧化氢储罐建造的。所以我们终于有了真正字面意义上的喷气背包。但现实是人们并没有那么热情。澳大利亚有一位名叫大卫·迈蒙的喷气背包飞行员。几年前，他在悉尼港上空试飞了他的机器。这段影像相当震撼但在接受《卫报》采访时，迈蒙表示他对反应感到惊讶。这里是
a quote, I still remember flying around close enough to see the joggers and the people walking around the botanical area and some of them did not look up. The jetpack is loud, so I promise you, they heard me. But there I was, flying by on a jetpack. And they did not look up. Maybe in a world full of drones and billionaire rocket launches, the jetpack just isn't all that surprising. Bill's working with a class at a university in Buffalo to see if there's some way to do jetpacks sustainably. But his attention is on other things like climate change or his grandkids hockey game or the Christmas ornaments he's carving in his wood shop. The jetpack can feel totally beside the point.
一句引语，我仍然记得飞行时离得足够近，能看到慢跑者和在植物园周围散步的人，他们中的一些人并没有抬头看。喷气背包声音很大，所以我向你保证，他们听到我了。但当时我就在那里，坐着喷气背包飞过。而他们竟然没有抬头看。也许在一个充满了无人机和亿万富翁火箭发射的世界里，喷气背包已经不那么令人惊讶了。比尔正在和布法罗一所大学的一个班级合作，看看有没有什么办法以可持续的方式制造喷气背包。但他的注意力集中在其他事情上，比如气候变化、他孙子们的曲棍球比赛，或者他在木工车间里雕刻的圣诞饰品。喷气背包感觉完全无关紧要了。
Yeah, you know, I don't have any any problem with any of it. But we've got to move on. the point. The rocket belt is a technology of the future that belongs to the past. But I understand why Wendell Moore and Bell Aerospace kept going. I understand why hobbyists kept trying to develop a better jet pack. Even after it was obvious, there wasn't going to be a jet pack in every driveway. They just had to know what was possible.
是的，你知道的，我对这一切都没有任何意见。但我们必须向前看了。无关紧要。火箭腰带是一项属于过去的未来技术。但我理解为什么温德尔·摩尔和贝尔航空航天公司会坚持下去。我理解为什么业余爱好者不断尝试开发更好的喷气背包。即使在很明显不可能每个车库里都有一个喷气背包之后。他们只是必须知道什么是可能的。
It's the same reason we go on a first date or go to the moon. It's the same reason I had to find the Rocket Man. And the same reason I went to not one, but two aerospace museums looking for an old rocket belt. Just to know for sure that they exist. We're going to take this out so you can... Wait, really? We can actually do that? Oh my gosh, Don.
这和我们第一次约会或去月球的原因是一样的。这也是我必须找到“火箭人”的原因，也是我去了一家又一家航空博物馆寻找旧火箭腰带的原因。就是为了确信它们确实存在。我们要把它拿出来，这样你就能……等等，真的吗？我们真的可以这么做吗？哦天哪，唐。
Don't tell my boss. I'm in trouble. Sometimes the magnet of curiosity is just too strong. Sometimes we just have to know more. Oh, wow. Oh, man, finally. I can't believe it. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Pack Hoaxes. More with Chris Berube after this. We are back with Chris Berube. Chris, you have been working on this story for quite
别告诉我老板。我有麻烦了。有时好奇心的磁石实在是太强大了。有时我们就是想知道更多。哦，哇。哦，天哪，终于。我真不敢相信。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈>
a while and it is finally here. I know. Yeah, I did my first interview for this story two years ago, I think. Yeah, two years ago. So why did it take so long? It took a while largely because I had to persuade Bill Souter to speak with me. So I sent him an email after I read David's article in the Washington Post. And his first response to me, I have this written down, I have no idea of how a podcast works nor do I care to learn.
好一段时间了，它终于完成了。我知道。是的，我想我两年前第一次为这个故事做采访。是的，两年前。那为什么花了这么长时间？花这么长时间主要是因为我必须说服比尔·苏特（Bill Souter）和我谈谈。我在《华盛顿邮报》上读到大卫的文章后给他发了一封电子邮件。他给我的第一回复是，我把这个记下来了，我不知道播客是怎么运作的，我也不想去了解。
So that was his reply. We communicated on and off for two years and I guess I won him over eventually because he's in the story. I mean, I think he might be onto something about podcasts though. You got to keep track of so many podcasts. It's not worth it. Don't start if you haven't started. That's probably the best advice. Probably true. But thanks for bearing with me during the reporting. I know this was a long one, but I want to talk to you about something that came up for me while I was reporting this, while I was talking to people about jetpacks for the last
这就是他的回复。我们断断续续交流了两年，我想我最终赢得了他的信任，因为他出现在这个故事里。我的意思是，不过我觉得他可能对播客有些看法。你必须追踪那么多的播客。不值得。如果你还没开始，那就别开始了。这可能是最好的建议。可能确实如此。但谢谢你在我做报道期间对我的包容。我知道这是一个很长的故事，但我想跟你谈谈我在做这个报道时遇到的一件事，在过去两年里和人们谈论喷气背包时，
two years, which is I heard from a couple of people, oh, jetpacks, the invention of jetpacks, like what the Nazis did. Like a couple of people said that to me when I was bringing up this story. So where did they get that idea? They got it online, believe it or not, the source of all knowledge, the internet. And I talked to Steve Leto about this. Of course, he wrote The Great American Jetpack, a very important book in this story, great resource for jetpack history.
也就是我从几个人那里听到，哦，喷气背包，喷气背包的发明，就像纳粹做的那样。当我提起这个故事时，有好几个人对我说过这样的话。那他们是从哪里得到这个想法的？信不信由你，他们是从网上得到的，所有知识的发源地，互联网。我和史蒂夫·莱托（Steve Leto）谈过这件事。当然，他写了《伟大的美国喷气背包》，这是这个故事中非常重要的一本书，是了解喷气背包历史的重要资源。
Anyhow, Steve told me it is very common to find stories like this online. And this particular one, the Nazi one, is not true in his reporting. In fact, it's part of this big lineage of fake jetpack news. There were a bunch of hoaxes I ran across while researching jetpacks. And one of them was that the Germans had invented
不管怎样，史蒂夫告诉我，在网上找到这样的故事是很常见的。而这个关于纳粹的故事在他的报道中并不是真的。事实上，它是关于虚假喷气背包新闻的巨大血统的一部分。我在研究喷气背包时遇到了很多骗局。其中之一就是德国人在二战中发明了
the jetpack in World War II by strapping the engine of a V1 buzz bomb to the back of a soldier so he could hop over trenches. And that struck me as being false for a bunch of reasons. Number one, trenches were World War I. Number two, the buzz bomb engine was actually quite heavy. It was a pulse jet engine. And none of it made any sense.
喷气背包，把V1飞弹发动机绑在士兵的背上，这样他就可以跳过战壕。出于很多原因，我觉得这是假的。第一，战壕是第一次世界大战的产物。第二，飞弹发动机实际上相当重。那是一个脉冲喷气发动机。而且这一切都说不通。
So where does this story come from? Steve looked into it. This story appears to have come from a Holocaust denier. Oh, goodness. Okay. And I ran the origin down to a guy who was a conspiracy theorist who liked to go on TV shows and rant about how much he hated certain ethnic groups. And he found out that he said, I want to go on there and rant about ethnic groups. They wouldn't let him. But if he said, I want to get on there and talk about German invented jetpacks, they go, oh, come on out.
那这个故事是从哪里来的呢？史蒂夫查阅了资料。这个故事似乎源自一个大屠杀否认者。噢，天哪。好吧。我顺藤摸瓜找到了一个阴谋论者，他喜欢上电视节目，怒斥他多么讨厌某些族群。他发现他说，我想上节目去痛骂某些族群。他们不让他去。但如果他说，我想上节目谈谈德国人发明的喷气背包，他们就会说，哦，快来吧。
And he just invented the story. He admitted it later. He later said, I made the story up. And yet I found websites that had repeated the story as if it was true. And they even had photographs. And the photograph of course, the GI Joe with a model of a pulse jet glued to his back. And it's kind of blurry. It's like, it's obviously a model. Yeah. So Roman, I know I've shared the link with you if you want to take a look at the picture. Okay. I got to see this. Okay. Oh my God. That is a doll. That is not a person. That's not a person. It's a little blurry. So like at first glance, if you're not
然后他编造了这个故事。他后来承认了。他后来承认，我编造了这个故事。然而我却发现一些网站把这个故事当作真的来重复。他们甚至还有照片。那张照片当然是，一个G.I. Joe（特种部队）模型，背上粘着一个脉冲喷气发动机的模型。而且有点模糊。就像，这显然是一个模型。是的。所以，罗曼，我知道我把链接分享给你了，如果你想看看这张照片的话。好的。我得看看这个。好的。哦天哪。那是一个玩偶。那不是一个人。那不是一个人。有点模糊。所以就像乍一看，如果你不
looking very carefully, it kind of looks like a person. If you're not looking carefully and you've been hitting the head. You've never seen a doll before. Yeah. Exactly. of looks like a person. If you're not looking carefully, and you've been hidden in the head. You've never seen a doll before. Exactly. Or a human. The prescription's out of date. Yeah. I know.
仔细看，它看起来有点像人。如果你不仔细看，而且你的头部受过撞击。你从没见过玩偶吗？是的。没错了。看起来有点像人。如果你不仔细看，而且你的头部受过撞击。你从没见过玩偶吗？没错。或者是一个人类。处方过期了。是的。我知道。
It's so silly. Okay, so that's one common hoax, is this idea that the Nazis invented it. Another, there's this story out there about this Romanian inventor who claims that he invented a jetpack that predates the bell design. I invented the jetpack. The Americans stole it from me. They owe me a couple billion dollars. And I traced this story down and there's a museum in Romania that has one of his jetpacks on display and it's obviously not a jetpack. Steve did not get to go to the museum but he sent someone to take photos and yeah it looks homemade like it's not a real jet pack.
太傻了。好吧，这就是一个常见的骗局，也就是纳粹发明了这个东西的说法。另一个，外面流传着一个关于罗马尼亚发明家的故事，他声称自己发明了一个早于贝尔设计的喷气背包。我发明了喷气背包。美国人偷了我的。他们欠我几十亿美元。我追踪了这个故事，罗马尼亚有一家博物馆展出了他的一款喷气背包，那显然不是喷气背包。史蒂夫没有去成那家博物馆，但他派人去拍了照片，是的，它看起来像是自己做的，不像是一个真正的喷气背包。
And apparently news organizations would call this guy for proof, and he'd send the pictures of Bill Souter, of the guy from our jet pack story. Or Bob Quarters, this other like famous Bell rocket bell pilot. So once again, there's no merit to this story. And sadly, I found news organizations in Romania that ran interviews with the guy and he would talk about his jet pack and they'd slice in images of the bell rocket belts being used. Roman I think this whole thing speaks to a bigger issue that runs through the whole story we've been telling about rocket belts and jet packs and it's how these kind of short-circuit our
显然，新闻机构会打电话给这个人要求提供证据，而他会发送比尔·苏特的照片，也就是我们喷气背包故事里那个人的照片。或者鲍勃·夸特斯（Bob Quarters），另一个著名的贝尔火箭腰带飞行员。所以再一次，这个故事没有任何依据。可悲的是，我发现罗马尼亚的新闻机构采访了这个人，他谈论他的喷气背包，而他们则穿插播放了使用贝尔火箭腰带的画面。罗曼，我认为整件事说明了一个更大的问题，贯穿在我们讲述的关于火箭腰带和喷气背包的整个故事中，那就是这些东西是如何让我们的
brain I think when we think about them, like for science journalists, for everyday people, like our critical faculties can kind of go a little haywire when we're reading about the idea of jetpacks, right? I think we just get so excited, it's like, oh, we want them to be real. And I feel like we don't apply enough intellectual rigor when talking about it.
大脑短路的，当我们想到它们时，比如对于科学记者，对于普通人，当我们读到关于喷气背包的想法时，我们的批判性思维能力有点像会变得有点错乱，对吧？我想我们只是太兴奋了，就像，哦，我们希望它们是真的。我觉得我们在谈论它时没有运用足够的智力严谨性。
Right, right. I can see that, and I can also see is like, you see little rockets, you see humans, what's the problem here? You strap one to the other. There's a kind of like sense that you could kind of make one in your garage. And so I think that sort of weakens people's defenses when it comes to these kind of things.
对，对。我能理解，我也能看到，就像，你看到小火箭，你看到人类，这里有什么问题？你把一个绑在另一个上面。有一种感觉，你可以在车库里自己做一个。所以我觉得这削弱了人们对这类事情的防范心理。
Right, totally. And I think it's what runs through this whole story is like everybody is looking for the jet pack. Like there is a part of us that really wants it to become something. So I feel like that hope kind of overtakes our rational thinking around something like this. Totally. I think that's the cornerstone of your story,
对，完全如此。我觉得这就是贯穿整个故事的主线，就像每个人都在寻找喷气背包。我们内心深处有一部分真的很想让它变成现实。所以我觉得这种希望在某种程度上压倒了我们对这种事情的理性思考。完全如此。我想那是你故事的基石，
is that there's a piece of everyone's brain that is searching for their jetpack because we want it so badly. And it makes sense to me completely. I had so much fun watching the story develop. Thank you so much for reporting it and for your persistence of getting Bill Souter, who that man is a gem. Thanks so much, Roman.
那就是每个人大脑的一部分都在寻找他们的喷气背包，因为我们太渴望它了。这对我来说完全说得通。看着这个故事的发展我感到非常开心。非常感谢你的报道，以及你坚持不懈地找到了比尔·苏特，那个老头简直是个宝藏。非常感谢，罗曼。
I really appreciate that. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Barube, edited by Kelly Prime, mix and sound design by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real, fact checking by Graham Heysha. Special thanks this week to Bill and Cheryl Souter, the Udvar-Hazy Center, and Dawn Erwin at the Niagara Aerospace Museum, where you can see a real life rocket belt. You can read David Taylor's reporting about Bill Souter and the rocket belt in the Washington Post. Kathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstedt is the digital director, Delaney Hong is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Sarah Bake, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella
我真的很感激。本周的《百分之九十九隐形》由克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）制作，凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）负责混音和声音设计，音乐由天鹅座（Swan Real）创作，格雷姆·海沙（Graham Heysha）负责事实核查。本周特别感谢比尔和谢丽尔·苏特（Bill and Cheryl Souter）、乌德瓦-哈齐中心（Udvar-Hazy Center），以及尼亚加拉航空博物馆的唐·欧文（Dawn Erwin），在那里你可以看到现实生活中的火箭腰带。你可以在《华盛顿邮报》上阅读大卫·泰勒（David Taylor）关于比尔·苏特和火箭腰带的报道。凯西·图（Kathy Tu）是我们的执行制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特特（Kurt Kolstedt）是数字总监，德兰尼·洪（Delaney Hong）是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括莎拉·贝克（Sarah Bake）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、加布里埃拉
Gladney, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lasha Madon, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Nina Patuk, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites,
格拉德尼（Gladney）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·雷（Vivian Ley）、拉沙·马顿（Lasha Madon）、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado-Medina）、尼娜·帕图克（Nina Patuk）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一员，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站上找到我们，
as well as our brand new Discord server. There are about 3,500 people talking about architecture, talking about Power Broker, talking about all kinds of fun things. Please join us there. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及我们崭新的Discord服务器。大约有3500人在讨论建筑，讨论《权力掮客》，讨论各种有趣的事情。请加入我们。99PI.org上有通往该链接以及99PI每一期往期节目的链接。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。